emo is back and clubs are packed from
coast to coast I grew up listening to
this music and so I wanted to go back to
my roots whether you're going through
depression or you're having fun with
your friends
um there's so many emotions that's in
this music I think that this generation
is like hungry for it emo music spent
nearly 20 years underground but by the
early to mid 2000s it dominated rock
radio MTV and Myspace capturing the
pent-up anger sadness and confusion of
the post-911 era the counterculture
resonated with Outsider teens who didn't
quite fit in the music that came from
like 2001 to 2005 was really just a
shift inward like what is affecting me
in my life and how can I deal with it no
matter how much of a reject you were
like you always felt welcome at these
shows